وبالحديث مشاهدينا عن المعابر والمساعدات
فبعد عشره ايام على اسوا زلزال تشهده
المنطقه منذ قرن ورغم الكارثه الانسانيه
التي هزت العالم ما زالت المساعي الامميه
لايصال المساعدات الى شمال غربي سوريا
تواجه تحديات كثيره هنا على الحدود
السوريه التركيه يوجد اكثر من عشره معابر
ولكن ثلاثه منها لها اهميه كبرى بايصال
المساعدات الانسانيه لسكان شمال سوريا وهي
باب الهوى باب السلامه و باب الراعي كما
نشاهد بهذه الخارطه معبر باب الهوى هو في
الوقت الراهن المعبر الرسمي الوحيد في
شمال ادلب بقرار اممي اي بموجه بقرار مجلس
الامن الدولي وتسيطر على معبر باب الهوى
المعارضه السوريه وفصائلها العسكريه معبر
باب السلامه في منطقه اعزاز شمال حلب
سيساهم ايضا بشكل كبير بادخال المساعدات
الانسانيه الى هذه المنطقه المنكوبه طبعا
المعبر وافقت على فتح الامم المتحده مؤخرا
تسيطر عليها ايضا فصائل المعارضه السوريه
اما معبر الراعي في ريف حلب يعتبر ايضا
شريان رئيسي للمتضررين في المنطقه حيث
طالبت واشنطن ودول غربيه بفتحه لايصال
المساعدات واستجابت الامم المتحده لتلك
المطالب ووافقت على استخدامه بعد موافقه
نظام الاسد طبعا علما انه اي معبر اي معبر
الراعي هو تحت سيطره المعارضه السوريه
[موسيقى]